i don't want to give any spoilers away
and i don't want to ruin anything for
you yeah but like i would re-watch the
first two episodes with you wow swear
just to sit down and like be able to say
all the stuff that i was thinking to you
all right because she fell asleep and
also she doesn't like to talk during
stuff yeah yeah i like to pause and be
like see now what do you think's
happening yeah i love flying like
because right love talk about i don't
like she says talk about it after i do
it i'm gonna forget about it i'm gonna
forget about everything after i want to
talk right now in anticipation of what i
think and see if i'm right or not it's
part of the fun it's part of the fun
yeah i've been in relationships i've
been i've been i've gotten complaints
about the pausing
yeah i don't know and i'm just like i'm
like i i'll go like
if i pause it she's like oh come on but
i'm like would you mind pausing for a
second okay and then she'll be like
she'll pause it like go out and i go
i'll either be like what do you think
well let me tell you what i think this
is and then she's like ah
then we start again but then every once
in a while when she wants to say
something like what are you doing
going against your own thing here you're
paul you're pausing
love is a battle